Have you been
a lot of break up here?
That guy's been calling you out.
Have you talked about it?
How's Jones know that fighter?
Which one?
Oh,
Colby.
Colby is funny man.
Cobras and I know Colby and I also know very well.
One of Colby is really good friends.
Is My friend,
uh,
Cam Hanes.
They're live in the same town.
Why is this fucking with you?
Because he's,
it's good.
It's good.
You're really got to choose to be heal or hero.
And I would always go,
he'll,
he's all healed.
Oh,
it's so much more fun.
Go.
He'll,
you know what's really hilarious?
Chels son mad that I talked about what he does that I know that I talked about
with Colby does.
I go,
he's having fun.
he's playing up the role of the villain and he's selling papers cause you're the
fourth wall to the business.
It's so ridiculous.
Meanwhile,
he's given up the secrets of the business by talking about me giving up the
secrets of the business.
It's the dumbest shit of all time.
I can't tell if it's a work.
I can't tell if what he's doing he's doing,
if he's fake upset.
There was a point where Cheo was the best trash talker in sports.
Yeah,
no,
he was phenomenal.
He still is.
But the idea that you bring up the trash to the octagon,
it's thunder.
When Anderson Silva walks in,
it sounds like a mouse pissing on cotton.
It's like what the fuck?
I've never lost a fight in my life.
I've never lost a route of,
I've never lost one second of one fight in my love life and that.
Then he's like,
what about here where you're going to fucking stop.
Didn't matter.
He just kept going.
I loved it.
It was beautiful.
He's a smart guy but he's also getting us to talk about it and getting us to
talk about his show,
which I'll give him a plug right now cause I'm sure it's great.
He's an Ariel Helwani and chill son and have a new show called aerial and the
bad guy and you got to get that ESPN.
Shayle Kann,
he's the bad guy.
He's great at it.
He's great at us and he ranted and raved about us for like 10 minutes.
And then he and then brandy responded it and he came back with another 20
minutes.
You don't ever talk about the business,
first of all have to,
because my job is to call what I see.
My job is not I,
even when I'm promoting things,
if I'm promoting things,
I'm calling what I see.
If I say Francis and Ghana was the most terrifying heavyweight contender ever,
I say that because that's what I see.
I see him put Alistair Overeem into fucking orbits side of it.
So you're just talking about the fighting part.
That's what you're experts that I talk about.
Whatever I want to talk about.
Listen,
here's the deal chain.
You stick to fighting a promoting and let intelligence,
uh,
leave that here too intelligent people.
You're out of your class.
Fucking deal with it.
Whoa,
uneducated.
You're a high school dropout and you know it.
You're going to trash talk and that's it.
I don't think he's home with your wife.
I think he graduated from college.
No,
he didn't.
He fucking dropped out of high school early,
like sophomore year.
No.
That guy's dumb,
bro.
Chill.
Son is gone.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Have you ever talked to him?
Yes.
You told me two points above retarded.
Oh,
that's fat.
What are the points?
What points do you get when you got a real issue,
but we'll keep your mind just go.
The line that they have medically is like,
if you are barely retarded,
you're still not really retarded,
but I should be more politically correct with our use of that word,
mentally retarded
tab,
trans and trans start all.
You can't say that.
You can't say that it's illegal.
It's like depending on who's president,
you'll get arrested for that to come in for you.
I like chill.
I like what he does.
I have to talk about the fact that someone's talking shit to build up,
but it doesn't stop someone from talking shit.
It also makes it more fun to watch.
I know what the fuck it is and I like it.
People are going to like it.
It makes it more interesting.
It makes it look.